clearly the price of oil has had an
effect on the US economy but it hasn't
been pronounced I think as many people
feared I remember back in two thousand
two economists worth reading over that
possibility of forty or fifty dollar oil
well now we're at a hundred dollar oil a
lot of people don't like it but most of
us can still afford it now it's
definitely hurting a lot of people I'm
not making light of that and it's
definitely a lot of people who drive a
lot truckers they're feeling a big pitch
but I'll at 120 dollars you know I don't
know that'll be substantially different
from oil at 100 the price of gasoline is
going up but you know there are a lot of
other factors now that are coming into
the price of crude besides demand and
that is the falling value of the dollar
and a lot of speculators in the market
now affecting the price of crude so you
know how much the increased price will
have in what effect it will have you
know I can't predict that well I think
that you know in theory anyway the five
dollar a gallon price is one that people
often mentioned as one where huge
amounts of conservation people drive
will quit driving the carpool ride their
bikes I think that that makes some sense
but for myself I live in Austin I often
have to drive to houston if my choices
are taking the bus or flying or driving
myself I'm still going to probably by
five dollar a gallon gasoline and I
think that you know for as I recall
about two-thirds of the transportation
miles driven by civilians non non
commercial operators are people driving
to work so I think even at five dollars
a lot of people are going to pay it
because they have to get to work so I
think we haven't seen yet a price high
enough I think for a lot of societal
changes overall in terms of the end of
the suburbs or so on because we still
see gasoline as a necessity and I think
for many people that still isn't will be
for a long time to come